olá pessoal hoje vou ensinar o que fazer
que mais uma armadilha e esta com todas
as outras carnes meu canal que você
possa ter visto em outro lugar qualquer
você só poderá usar aulas em caso de
sobrevivência vivência é quando você
está em um lugar qualquer por exemplo a
zona montanhosa mesmo 100 na casa do
dono dos animais será logo documentário
qualquer animal ou pessoa pronta e
cansei de norma essa ajuda a fazer é
treinar outra qualquer e pronto
esta armadilha é mais para apanhar a luz
e pronto está feito não deu melhor
caso seja a companhia conseguiu mostrar
ser um pm masculina com um pequena ser
mais sensível pronto facilmente pelas
imagens em cima dessa linha pois
charolas não está a ser bem simples de
fazer
é só fazer uma espécie de bola na linha
será qa argola babaçu linha pelo por
dentro da escola
já agora entrando e por laço em cima
aqui o foco vai acionar o gatilho ou
seja quando o animal pisar vejo agora
pronto até o próximo vídeo pessoal
espero que tenham gostado sejam
responsáveis não é fazer uma boa estreia